welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and Marvel's what-if is one of the
more intriguing projects from Marvel's
future with most of the main MCU lineup
from the Avengers guardians of the
galaxy Thor Black Panther films all
returning to voice their characters in
insane alternate reality adventures we
may not see what caps life looks like
living through the 20th century with
knowledge of every horrible tragedy
coming up but we do hit the scene become
a zombie I'm gonna break down everything
we know about this what if series
visuals from the d23 trailer episodes
that have been confirmed and based on
this voice cast popular issues from the
what-if comic series that they might
adapt in episodes including since josh
brolin will be part of this an alternate
version of Thanos warning this
speculation is to write and that ruins
your life
okay Comic Con last July Marblehead
Kevin Feige revealed and upcoming
what-if series on Disney plus an
adaptation of the long-running Marvel
Comics series with hypothetical titles
like what if the Hulk had the brain of
Bruce Banner and by the way that what-if
kind of thinking inspired the end game
writers to show smart Hulk that Thor
murderous vigilante Hawkeye by introduce
Jeffrey Wright as The Watcher Watchers
or Marvel entities god-like beings who
observe and record all the events of the
multiverse watchers actually showed up
in The Guardian to the galaxy vol 2
Duncan one of Stanley's long-winded
stories Jeffrey Wright's watcher will
host this anthology series kind of like
Rod Serling for the twilight zone where
the Cryptkeeper from tales of the Crypt
it sounds like each episode will open
with the Watchers saying I am The
Watcher I am your guide through these
vast new realities follow me and dare to
face the unknown and ponder the question
what if and I assume that's followed by
a shrill Cryptkeeper cackle in the d23
trailer the Watchers voice described how
time is a prison of endless
possibilities and much of the footage
sitting around what we know is the pilot
episode
what if Peggy Carter received the Super
Soldier Serum animation showed Steve
Rogers entering the lab to receive the
Super Soldier Serum for the room
explodes and there's other imagery of
Peggy Carter in the chamber looking
ripped and she carries her own vibranium
shield as Captain Britain and the Marvel
Comics Captain Britain is actually Brian
Braddock an alternate version of Steve
Rogers Captain America writing actually
got an Easter eggs shout out and
Avengers in game 4 you're listening
closely but here Peggy Carter takes on
the mantle she stops a car with her
shield and flips it skinny Steve
Rogers will still play a role in this
episode shown in an old-school Iron
Monger type armored suit that Peggy
piggybacks on as she flies through the
air
perhaps Howard Stark designed his own
beta Iron Man armor that's what this is
we also know that Toby Jones will be
lending his voice of the series
suggesting that our names ona might
factor into this storyline now it has
been announced that all 23 MCU films are
going to showcase one change in each
episode but these series showrunners
clarified that some episodes will
feature multiple MCU properties all
crossing over into one episode one
example that is another episode we know
about what if T'Challa became star-lord
so in this reality Yan Duke Ragland the
Ravagers kidnapped the young wakandan
Prince instead of Peter quill this might
mean that this T'Challa was like quill
is the offspring of ego which is why the
Ravagers kidnapped quill or maybe the
Ravagers just took to Charlotte because
he's like a valuable earthling that they
could try to ransom but this would mean
two charla would not become the Black
Panther and king of Wakanda and since
Michael B Jordan will return him to
whatev series it appears as though we
will see what would happen to Wakanda if
kill monger took over uncontested and
carried out his vision for what Condon
supremacy on the planet we also know
that there will be other episodes that
featured the guardians of the galaxy
characters and one of the features Thor
characters like Thor Jane Foster
Loki cork and the Grand Master one
possible Thoris story could be what if
Loki was worthy of Neal near apparently
the what-if series writers wanted to do
a Jane Foster Thor story but they were
told to scrap that episode because Taika
Waititi obviously planned to adapt that
story arc for Thor xi under one of the
more recent what-if issues from 2015 was
what if Thanos joined the Avengers that
story featured the Avengers facing the
builders they annos offers his services
besides with Thor and the others to
fight the builders eventually they win
but the Avengers are left not being able
to trust a nose who offers to help them
become imperialist conquerors just like
him and in fact that end game featured
two different versions of Thanos the
older one who died in the beginning the
younger evil Irwin who died at the end
has led us to wonder what alternate
versions of Thanos could look like and
what if could be an excellent
opportunity to explore that like what if
Thanos joined the Avengers to fight ego
what if Thanos join the Avengers against
his younger self from 2014
what if Thanos hosts a cooking show we
never did
see how that Stu turned out additionally
it has been confirmed that what if will
feature an ant-man episode with Scott
Lang Hank Pym Kurt from Scott's crew I
assume it will be someone or something
being shrunken down or enlarged that
shouldn't be like what if Avengers Tower
was shrunken with everyone in it or what
if giant Scott Lang had to take a dump
like it's actually a debate over whether
Scotts accelerated metabolism while
giant size means his digesting food
doesn't grow with his organs the way
it's just best not to think about it too
much we also know that there will be a
Marvel Zombies episode what if the
Avengers were zombies perhaps adapted
from the Robert Kirkman Marvel series in
which Reed Richards opens a portal to
the zombie universe word zombie Avengers
consumed everything including eventually
Galactus d23 footage of Bucky fighting
zombie cap on a train suggest the Winter
Soldier will be the badass assigned to
take out every zombie Avenger we gotta
swap out that Winter Soldier arm parade
chainsaw baby sounds like Marvel is a
rights to feature spider-man in this
series since its animated and TV or
whatever TV is transforming into these
days though I don't think they will be
able to use the Tom Holland live-action
spider-man voice as the character it
sounds like the general idea of this
would've series is if it's successful
when it launches in summer 2021 is to
open the door of the MCU to endless
hypothetical else world style standalone
stories but hopefully Feige finds a way
to tie Geoffrey rights watch her into
the live-action MCU films as well like
perhaps a tease that the reality of
Doctor Strange or the multiverse of
madness or authorial of and thunder
could be what of many infinite realities
that The Watcher is keeping an eye on
what what if story do you want to see as
an episode comment down below with your
thoughts follow me on Twitter and
Instagram me a boss and subscribe to new
rock stars for breakdowns and theories
of everything Marvel thank you for
joining me and okay let's figure this
out this Scott Lang poops eyes if the
digesting food is independent of the
resizing what if when a shrinks does
that like [ __ ] squeezed out like
toothpaste and these are very important
questions
[Music]